je me présente tout dominique grondin
directeur sportif et financier de
l'entreprise pardon l'entreprise pardon
a été créée par monsieur mais hôtesses
peter en
1984 vous vous l'aurez compris
aujourd'hui on a 30 ans en trente années
d'existence
parsemer
parfois d'embûches mais de beaucoup de
créativité
ce qui a permis à la société
aujourd'hui
de compter 40 employés sur la réunion
et aux antilles nous avons vis boutique
sur l'île
de aux antilles une à maurice une à
mayotte mayotte c'est il s'agit d'un
revendeur et nous sommes en train de
développer la métropole au travers de
corner et de revente dans des commerces
pardon recherche pour le secteur nord
une vendeuse ou un vendeur la ville
d'affectation sera sainte clotilde cette
personne devrait être impliqué souriante
savoir accueillir le client savoir
conseiller
maîtriser les encaissements en plus de
toutes ces qualités le vendeur la
vendeuse qui sera retenu devra respecter
la charpente donc c'est à dire venir
travailler dans la bonne humeur
s'habiller en pardon adopter une allure
générale dynamique et décalé par rapport
aux vendeurs des autres enseignes donc
si vous vous reconnaissez
dans ce profil envoyez nous votre
candidature